[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Charlene yeah Jake you want to go to
prom with me I thought you'd never ask
I would love to I don't know why I was
just so nervous hey Jake yeah Charlie
did you know that only like two percent
of high school sweethearts wind up
married and more than half of them end
up divorced
yeah I mean when you think about it with
seven point four billion people on earth
the odds that we'd find our soulmates in
this small town of a thousand three
hundred and seventy-nine people is
mathematically impossible so we agree I
mean we're good with this for the time
being but it's not gonna be like a long
term thing oh of course not I never want
to be in a relationship when I go off to
college I love that about you and I love
you
until orientation week and then we won't
ever talk again
oh yeah obviously 27 minutes in 35
seconds cocktail game mutters damn Oh
Calvin 27 minutes and 29 seconds 28
seconds 27 seconds 6 seconds bundle up
on love all right boys listen up
big game tonight
yeah
wise man once said to me life is a game
of inches and every inch we need is
around us we tear Zelda pieces at each
and claw with our fingernails
for that inch it's nothing any given
Sunday speech yes what do I have to do
to greet you guys if you lose I'm gonna
be known as losers now and forever
you won't be known as losers the rest of
your lives
huh huh huh
we're not losers coach what's that we
love football but but you're ruining it
most of us won't ever play again at the
end of the season but we will go on to
be doctors and lawyers and teachers
football is just a game
but life yeah life
is what we choose to make of it
Jai Ramji
you are about four stupidest kid ever
met my entire life I'm done coach was
that me I'm not playing tonight me too
me too no I don't ruin this for me if we
win tonight I got a job waiting for me
at Texas City junior college wait
they have a football team uh-huh and
I'll be the special assistant of the
special teams coach if I win than that
if we win than that well then come on
boys let's go get ourselves a win and
never see coach again
[Applause]
[Applause]
you